comme l’âme même de la ville.
En fait, n’importe qui peut témoigner de la présence
du vaste réseau d’eau de la rivière
à travers toute la ville,
dans des endroits tels que les fontaines publiques et privées.
Malheureusement, à cause de la pollution,
la rivière a été recouverte petit à petit
par des blocs de béton à partir de 1952
Ce processus d’effacement était couplé
avec la destruction de plusieurs maisons
le long des berges de la rivière
pour permettre à des engins
de pénétrer l’étroit réseau piétonnier de la Médina
Ces vides urbains sont rapidement devenus des parkings illégaux
ou des dépôts d'ordures.
En fait, l’état de la rivière
avant d’entrer dans la Médina était assez sain.
Puis la pollution a fait des ravages,
surtout, à cause des eaux usées non traitées
et des rejets chimiques des activités comme le tannage.
Il est arrivé un moment où je ne pouvais plus supporter
la profanation de la rivière,
une part si importante de ma ville,
et j’ai décidé d’agir,
spécialement après avoir appris que la ville
recevait une subvention pour détourner les eaux usées
et les traiter.
Avec de l’eau propre, soudain,
le recouvrement de la rivière est devenu impossible,
et avec de la chance et beaucoup d’aide,
mon coéquipier Takako Tajima et moi
avons été commissionnés par la ville
pour travailler avec une équipe d’ingénieurs
pour dévoiler la rivière.
Cependant nous étions ambitieux,
et avons proposé plus :
transformer les berges de la rivière en allées piétonnes,
et ensuite faire rejoindre ces allées
au réseau de la ville,
et enfin aménager les vides urbains
le long de la rivière en espaces publics,
ce qui manque à la Médina de Fez.
Maintenant, je vais brièvement vous montrer
deux de ces espaces publics.
Le premier est la Place Rcif,
qui est situé juste au-dessus de la rivière,
que vous pouvez voir ici en pointillés.
Cette place était utilisée comme une plaque tournante des trnsports
qui compromettait l’intégrité urbaine
de la Médina, qui a le plus grand
réseau piéton au monde.
Et juste au-delà du pont historique que vous pouvez voir ici,
juste à côté de la place,
vous voyez que la rivière ressemblait
à une rivière de détritus.
Au lieu de ça, nous avons proposé de rendre
la place entièrement piétonne,
de la couvrir d'auvents en cuir recyclés
et de la relier aux berges de la rivière.
Le second site d'intervention
est aussi un vide urbain le long de la rive,
qui autrefois était un parking illégal
que nous avons proposé de transformer
en un espace de jeu pour la Médina.
Cet espace est construit à partir de pneus recyclés
et est aussi associé à un marécage construit
pour nettoyer l'eau de la rivière
ainsi que pour contenir d'éventuelles inondations
A mesure que le projet évoluait
et que nous recevions des prix de conception,
de nouvelles parties prenantes intervenaient
et changeaient les objectifs et la conception du projet.
Le seul moyen pour nous d'atteindre
les principaux objectifs du projet
était de faire quelque chose d'assez inhabituel
que généralement les architectes ne font pas.
Il s'agissait de mettre notre égo
et nos droits d'auteur de côté,
se mettre en retrait
essentiellement militer
et essayer de coordonner
les agendas des parties prenantes
pour se concentrer sur l'objectif principal :
libérer la rivière, retraiter son eau,
et offrir des espaces publics pour tous.
Nous sommes en fait très chanceux,
et la plupart des objectifs sont atteints
ou le seront bientôt.
On peut ici le constater, à la place Rcif
Voilà à quoi elle ressemblait 6 ans plus tôt
Et voici ce qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui
Elle est encore en travaux,
mais est déjà très fréquentée
par la population locale.
Au final, voilà à quoi ressemblera la place Rcif
quand le projet sera terminé.
La rivière, recouverte, utilisée comme une déchetterie
Puis après plusieurs années de travail,
l'eau propre de la rivière, découverte.
Et finalement ici la rivière
lorsque le projet sera finalisé.
Le projet de Réhabilitation de la Rivière de Fez
continuera d'évoluer et de s'adapter
au contexte socio-politique de la ville,
mais nous croyons fortement qu'en réinventant
le rôle et le métier de l'architecte,
nous avons mis en place le cœur du projet
qui est de métamorphoser une rivière polluée
en espace public pour tous,
ainsi s'assurer que la ville de Fez
restera une ville vivante pour ses habitants
plutôt qu'un patrimoine disparu.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)